well it's the one year mark for the
biden regime and with a 33 approval in
the latest poll it's clear that he
basically gets no marks from the
american people for his devastatingly
bad performance how does it make those
trump-hating democrats and their media
servants feel to learn that biden is
below where trump was after his first
year that's because biden is the worst
president in american history he said it
shut down the pandemic make the economy
work for everyone bring competence to
government restore american leadership
in the world instead with a pandemic
raging inflation soaring supply chain
crisis border crisis of course the
afghanistan crisis america's feeble
failing president is a laughing stock
around the world
as maureen dowd wrote in the new york
times today
people wanted competence and stability
and instead we get incompetence and
instability
biden didn't do anything he promised his
legislative agenda lies in tatters his
deal-making prowess we're all told about
reveal as a complete joke
three times biden was wheeled out to try
and persuade his own party in congress
to back him and three times they told
him to drop dead
but even among all these disasters there
is one that stands out one so
egregiously so completely contradictory
to what we were promised that it's in a
league of shame all its own
the one thing biden actually had a
mandate for
was to bring the country together he
said so himself in his inaugural address
a year ago
stop the shouting and lower the
temperature politics doesn't have to be
a raging fire we must end this uncivil
war
and this week almost a year on from
those promises of unity we saw biden
throw them on a bonfire of his own
making the president of the united
states reduced to the abject spectacle
of a tawdry race hustler riling up his
base to cover up his failure
deliberately dividing the country for
his own partisan ends
biden went to georgia to push voting
rights but his reckless rant instead
pushed biden into the rotten stinking
swamp of dishonest divisive demagoguery
biden's rant in atlanta must surely go
down as one of the most disgraceful
speeches any president has made the man
who promised to unite the country now
labeling anyone who disagrees with him a
domestic enemy
i'll defend the right to vote our
democracy against all enemies
domestic
and just in case that wasn't clear
enough he helpfully explained who you'd
be with if you're his domestic enemy
you want to be the sign the side of dr
king
or george wallace
you want to be in the side of john lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
apparently that little piece of juvenile
demagoguery was actually written
by this man john meacham who pops up on
msnbc all the time claiming to be a
historian a historian
funny how these autocratic leaders who
treat their opponents as enemies of the
state always end up with regime
propagandists who dress up their fascism
as principal john meacham the author of
the rant in atlanta yeah he's a
historian just like lenny reefenstein is
a documentary filmmaker
biden the democrats and their
propagandists like meacham are using the
tactic of the authoritarian tyrant
through the ages manufacture a crisis in
order to justify a crackdown they're
trying to convince people especially
black people that their voting rights
are being taken away by organized
targeted voter suppression by
republicans they think that if they say
it enough people will believe it
but every single specific allegation
turns out to be a democrat lie
there's the lie about getting rid of
election officials
in georgia the restrictive voting law
enacted in march gives unchecked power
to the state election board to remove
local election officials we heard about
these partisan takeovers of elections at
our field hearing in atlanta from one
election
official who had been ousted
by the state legislature after over a
decade of service
according to biden's rant in atlanta
this is election subversion
but there's an almost identical
provision in the democrat bill biden
wants to push through congress the
georgia law
says states can suspend local election
officials for quote non-seasons
malfeasance or gross negligence
biden's own bill
says states can suspend local election
officials for quote gross negligence
neglect of duty or malfeasance in office
there's the lie that voter id is racist
voter suppression but the mayor of
washington dc who painted black lives
matter on the street outside the white
house has just introduced voter id for
leaving your house
why was the decision made not to require
a valid photo id when someone let's say
presents
their covid vaccine card i think we do
expect to require that
and sure enough she did here's her
little tweet starting saturday you will
need photo id before heading out
if we apply the democrats voting rights
argument that's worse than voter
suppression that's extrajudicial house
arrest for black people time to send the
department of justice civil rights
division in to arrest muriel bowser
there's the lie about drop boxes racist
georgia lawmakers taking them off the
streets when they were actually putting
them on the streets
in 2019 drop boxes were completely
illegal in georgia now they're enshrined
in law
there's the lie about mail-in voting
thanks to the new republican law anyone
in georgia can request a mail-in ballot
whereas in biden's delaware you need to
give a reason in chuck schumer's new
york you need to sign an attestation
that you're out of town ill caring for
someone who's ill in a veterans facility
or in jail it is a felony to make a
false statement in an application for an
absentee ballot the instructions worn
yet schumer calls the georgia law
dastardly
he points to the consolidation of early
voting places in one rural county as
being part of some january the six star
plot to stop black people voting but the
black woman in charge of voting in that
county says they've been planning the
change for years it's driven by
declining numbers of voters in any case
quote we have advanced voting we have
absentee ballots and we will also have
transportation oh and by the way it's a
68 republican county
on and on it goes lie after lie after
lie whether it's drop boxes or mail-in
voting or early voting or voter id
election rules which are less
restrictive than in many democrat-run
states described by democrats as the new
jim crow do they ever stop to think
about what they're actually saying what
their words even mean
under jim crow schools restaurants buses
were segregated
it was evil shameful disgusting and now
for biden and the democrats to use the
specter of jim crow to advance their own
partisan power grab well yeah that's
evil and that's shameful and that is
disgusting
biden pelosi harris all of them they are
reckless racial arsonists as usual
guilty of the exact thing they accuse
others of
and then when you ask yourself why
it gets even worse
what's the reason
biden went to atlanta to deliver this
ill-judged appalling rant well would you
believe it chuck todd gave us the answer
just this morning
you know i'm not i was told by somebody
in the white house said look they're
like
uh the activists are angry he had to do
this like that was the argument if he
didn't do this they weren't going to
have people to lick envelopes
in in senate races and house races
licking envelopes
because they're worried about not having
enough people to lick envelopes for
their election campaigns they rub salt
in america's most painful wounds
that's what this whole thing is about
and it shows what democrats are all
about for them it is always
about politics not policy point scoring
not principle pandering to their base
instead of leading the country
and the lies aren't just about voting
specifics the whole story they're
telling is a lie
they say republicans are trying to
suppress the vote because they feared
demographic change
but in the 2020 presidential election
the black republican vote went up the
latino republican vote went up a lot
while the latino vote for democrats went
down a lot
thanks to trump's conservative populism
the republican party is becoming a
multi-racial working-class coalition
while the democrats become the party of
the rich white and woke
this is the actual factual demographic
reality the more that non-white citizens
vote the better it is for republicans
and the worse it is for democrats
the democrats say they're trying to save
democracy
they're the ones undermining it look
what's in their voting legislation
nationalizing elections unconstitutional
undermining voter roll accuracy
unacceptable abolishing voter id laws
unconscionable and the whole stinking
pile of anti-democratic corrupt garbage
crowned by their attempt to expand the
banana republic atrocity of ballot
harvesting
and then
the goal the former president's allies
is to disenfranchise anyone who votes
against them they'll just decide what
they want
and then do it
that's the kind of power you see in
totalitarian states
not in democracies
biden rants about authoritarianism
excuse me
but who is sending in the fbi to
intimidate parents who disagree with
democrat schools policy whose regime is
it in an absolutely chilling new
development that just announced this
domestic violent extremists are often
motivated by a mix of ideologies and
personal grievances
we've seen a growing threat from those
who are motivated by racial animus as
well as those who ascribe to extremist
anti-government and anti-authority
ideologies i've decided to establish a
domestic terrorism unit
to augment our existing approach
we have run out of words to express how
dangerous and frightening this all is if
you're anti-authority
you're a domestic terrorist
if you disagree with biden you're a
domestic enemy and if you speak out
against this if you try to protect free
speech and democracy you're the
authoritarian
as biden approaches his first baleful
anniversary in office it's hard to
overstate what a disaster this man is
the economy the pandemic the border
foreign policy everything engulfed in
chaos and failure
biden should have been impeached over
afghanistan he should be removed with
the 25th amendment over his obvious
senility
but after the rant in atlanta we can say
for sure that if he had any decency any
dignity he would resign in shame over
the hate and division he's bringing to
this country
follow us at steve hilton x and hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else